l'univers est un vide parsemé de
quelques planètes inhabitables des
astéroïdes et des copies de notre soleil
très très loin dans l'espace c'est faux
si je vous disais que perdu quelque part
on pouvait trouver un réservoir d'eau
pouvant remplir 140 millions de fois
tous les océans il se trouve dans la
constellation du lynx sous forme de
vapeur en son centre l'un des trous
noirs les plus énormes qu'on ait observé
et qui continue de grossir grâce à tout
le gaz et la matière qui gravitent
autour de lui il pourrait
potentiellement atteindre 6 fois sa
taille actuelle il y a beaucoup d'autres
objets dont vous ne soupçonnez même pas
l'existence défiant les lois de la
physique le plus chaud le plus puissant
le plus grand le plus rapide le plus
dangereux découvrons ces choses cachées
dans l'univers qui brise tous les
records savez-vous que les câbles qui
servent à rendre Internet accessible
font plus d'un million de kilomètres
trois fois la distance Terre-Lune ça
vous impressionne pour protéger
sécuriser vos données vous pouvez faire
appel à notre partenaire cybergot VPN
vous connaissez probablement le principe
d'un VPN un trou de Dr numérique vous
permettant de contourner les physique et
les restrictions géographiques cybergotz
VPN est le vaisseau de choix pour
naviguer dans notre univers en ligne
imaginez pouvoir explorer les versions
américaines de Netflix Disney plus et
toutes vos plateformes de streaming
préféré vous allez pouvoir découvrir
tous les joyaux cachés des séries et
films en vous géolocalisant dans le pays
de votre choix mais en plus cyberGhost
VPN va vous faire économiser de l'argent
en mettant votre IP en Argentine ou en
Inde vous paierez moins votre abonnement
Spotify et Disney plus par mois et vous
n'imaginez pas les économies que vous
pouvez faire pour vous réservations de
vacances comme ça cybergot ZPN est aussi
un allié fiable avec 38 millions
d'utilisateurs satisfaits et 5 étoiles
sur trust pilot vous avez accès à un
service client 24h sur 24 grâce à notre
super offre profitez de 83% de réduction
et 4 mois gratuits satisfait ou
remboursés sous 45 jours c'est 2 euros
par mois et vous pouvez l'utiliser sur
cet appareil différent PC mobile console
TV ça marche partout le lien est en
description quelle est la plus grande
chose de l'univers notre Soleil à la
taille de 109 terres empilées c'est
drôle parce que sans neuf c'est
exactement le nombre de qu'on pourrait
aligner jusqu'à la terre et bien prenez
cette fois sa distance terre soleil et
vous avez une super géante rouge comme
scutty la plus grande étoile de
l'univers jusqu'ici observé 1700 fois
notre Soleil sa taille elle la doit en
partie à son âge après avoir consommé
presque tout l'hydrogène qui la compose
elle produit plus assez d'énergie pour
stabiliser son enveloppe donc elle
grandit dans notre système ça donnerait
ça elle recourirait carrément Jupiter
tellement lumineuse que Neptune pourtant
la plus éloignée retirer vivante il y
aurait bien une zone habitable à 1000
milliards de kilomètres mais on vous la
conseille pas sculpty est en train de
mourir c'est une baudruche qui gonfle
qui gonfle mais dans quelques millions
d'années la fusion de ses composants va
créer un noyau de fer ce compresseur
continuellement sur lui-même puis un
jour l'énergie dégagée par la fusion ne
sera plus suffisante pour contrebalancer
la gravité l'étoile s'effondre sur
elle-même c'est une super nova là même
10 fois plus éloignée que nepsune tout
sera rasé par l'un des événements les
plus violent que notre galaxie est
jamais connu six utile la plus grande
des étoiles ce n'est pas la plus massive
seulement 30 fois la masse du Soleil un
gros ballon de plasma à la gravité si
forte que la température et la pression
permettent une fusion nucléaire le titre
de la plus massive revient à r136 A1
situé à 163000 années-lumière dans la
nébuleuse de la tarenture 230 fois la
masse du Soleil tellement chaude et
puissante qu'elle n'arrive pas à retenir
sa propre masque qui déborde de partout
ce type d'étoiles on appelle ça une
wolfrayette contrairement aux autres
comme le soleil qui sont composés
d'hélium et d'hydrogène là on y trouve
beaucoup de carbone d'azote et d'autres
éléments lourds ce qui la rend huit fois
plus chaude mais aussi plus éphémère à
côté les naines Jones comme le soleil
c'est plutôt 10 milliards elle naissent
en déstructures gigantesques des
pouponnières stellaires les nébuleuses
ces immenses nuages de gaz et de
poussière célestes qui se forment
souvent à la suite d'une super nova ils
sont parfaits pour créer des étoiles il
suffit d'une petite instabilité
pour que cette matière s'effondre sous
sa propre attraction se compresse et
comment ça chauffer si elle atteint 10
puissance 7 Calvin elle devient capable
de fusionner son hydrogène en hélium
c'est le début de vie de l'étoile une
nébuleuse a observé c'est magnifique
mais c'est surtout vertigineux pour les
mesurer on parle en année lumière année
lumière c'est long 2108 systèmes
solaires mis bout à bout avec une fusée
ça vous prendrez environ 27000 ans et
vous arriveriez seulement à la moitié de
la nébuleuse du boomerang et c'est pas
une très grande le record c'est la
nébuleuse de la tarentule 1480
années-lumière de diamètre 3 millions de
système solaire à aligner vous pouvez
même en voir certaines à l’œil nu dans
l'hémisphère Nord on a Orion repéré la
constellation d'Orion en forme de
sablier elle est juste sous les trois
étoiles alignés les tapotus c'est les
galaxies là les chiffres n'ont presque
plus de sens notre Voie Lactée par
exemple c'est 105000 années-lumière 71
nébuleuses de la tarentule 220 millions
de système solaire si ça vous donne le
vert vous êtes pas prêt pour la plus
grande de toutes les galaxies actionner
16 millions d'années-lumière 152 voies
lactées alignées on l'a découvert
récemment en février 2022 grâce au lOFAR
le plus grand radio télescope du monde
mais si je vous disais qu'il existait
quelque chose d'encore plus grand car
les galaxies sont liées entre elles par
des forces de gravité pour former des
superamas nous on est dans celui de
Lania Kea 522 millions d'années-lumière
de diamètre juste ici les centaines de
milliers de galaxies qui le composent
sont liées par une mystérieuse force le
grand attracteur une anomalie
gravitationnelle qui tient tout ce beau
monde ensemble une masse titanesque dont
on ignore la nature et qu'on ne peut pas
observer car c'est du côté de la voie
lactée qui nous est invisible caché par
le gros trou noir central faudra
attendre 100 millions d'années de
rotation pour être bien placé si vous
trouvez la niakea majestueux il n'est
qu'une poussière à côté des mastodontes
le plus imposant superamas et le grand
mur d'Hercule couronne boréales 10
milliards d'années-lumière
aligner pour essayer de mettre en
perspective à quel point ces
gigantesques rappelez-vous que l'univers
n'a que 13,8 milliards d'années ça veut
dire que même à la vitesse de la lumière
traversez le grand mur demanderait
presque autant de temps que l'existence
de l'existence on peut seulement se
perdre à imaginer quel sera la prochaine
découverte si on continue de dézoomer
qui sait on apprendra peut-être que même
les super Hamas sont liés entre eux
quels sont les limites de l'observable
dans les années 2000 les journaux
titraient avoir découvert une étoile
plus vieille que l'univers 16 milliards
d'années on l'a surnomma donc étoile de
Mathusalem un patriarche biblique qui
aurait vécu presque 1000 ans c'est
seulement en 2021 avec de nouvelles
méthodes de calcul qu'on a ré estimé son
âge à 13,7 milliards d'années soit à
l'âge de l'univers ou les lois de la
physique sont sauvées et il est
seulement à 202 années-lumière de nous
le doyen de l'espace et dans notre
galaxie du moins jusqu'à ce qu'on lui
trouve un remplaçant car depuis on peut
voir beaucoup plus loin dans l'espace
tant vu qu'on ne peut pas aller plus
vite que la lumière on ne vois aucun
objet à plus de 13,7 milliards
d'années-lumière de nous non le temps
qu'elle nous parvienne si on peut
observer des choses dans un télescope
c'est parce qu'elles émettent de la
lumière c'est pour ça qu'on a galéré
avoir les trous noirs comme ils
absorbent la lumière ils sont invisibles
dans quelque chose est à une
année-lumière de nous ça veut dire qu'il
faut une année pour que ça luminosité
nous attaigne ce qu'on voit sur le
télescope c'est une photo du passé sauf
que l'univers est en perpétuel expansion
il continue de grandir et toujours plus
vite chaque fois qu'il augmente de 3,3
millions d'années-lumière son expansion
accélère de 73 km/h du coup ça fausse
les longues distances ainsi l'univers
observable fait plus de 93 milliards
d'années-lumière de diamètre ainsi le
télescope James web pense avoir observer
la galaxie la plus éloignée et la plus
vieille de toutes ces 9 3 3 1 6 trouver
lui un nom style s'il vous plaît elle
serait à 34,6 milliards d'années-lumière
de nous avec une date de naissance
estimée à 235,8 millions d'années après
le Big Bang mais peut-être encore plus
vieux juste sous notre nez par exemple
vous savez que les trous noirs
n'émettent aucune lumière mais ce ne
sont pas les seuls à se cacher
laissez-moi vous présenter Kepler un B
officiellement connu comme la planète la
plus sombre de l'univers situé dans la
constellation du Dragon a un peu plus de
7000 années-lumière elle ne reflète que
1% de la lumière qui la touche on s'est
rendu compte de son existence quand la
voyant passer devant son propre soleil
on ne sait pas exactement pourquoi elle
est si sombre ça pourrait être à cause
de la présence de composés chimiques qui
absorbe la lumière ou encore l'absence
de nuages réfléchissant comme on peut
trouver sur Jupiter car on est limité
non seulement à la taille de l'univers
observable mais à ce qu'on peut voir
aussi il suffit qu'un télescope se
tourne pile au bon endroit dans
l'immensité du ciel et toutes nos
convictions pourrai s'effondrer et ça
serait pas la première fois que ça
arrive ces records qui défilent les lois
de la physique savez-vous qu'il existe
une planète de glace sur laquelle vous
pourriez mourir de chaud il y a s436b et
juste à côté de son soleil la
température la surface avoisine les 440
degrés alors que la planète est
constituée d'eau en fait la gravité la
pression sont si que malgré la chaleur
l'eau ne peut pas s'évaporer les
molécules sont compressées à l'état
solide de la glace brûlante dans
l'univers toutes les situations les plus
extrêmes sont possibles savez-vous qu'on
pouvait créer un réfrigérateur stellaire
à partir d'une étoile prenez la
nébuleuse du boomerang en son centre une
géante rouge en fin de vie qui expulse
son gaz mais elle le fait beaucoup trop
vite après ce que 6000 km/h ce qui
produit un phénomène similaire à celui
de ton frigo le gars se dilate et perd
son énergie thermique on vous en avez
parlé dans cette vidéo ça en fait
l'endroit le plus froid de l'univers
moins 272 degrés un degré au-dessus du
zéro absolu normalement l'espace est un
peu plus chaud que ça c'est pour ça que
l'endroit le plus froid de l'univers en
fait et sur Terre avec des machines ok
pour les records de froid mais est-ce
qu'il y a une température maximale
l'endroit le plus chaud possible au
Conseil européen pour la recherche
nucléaire en Suisse on a réussi à
atteindre 5000 milliards de degrés pour
produire un plasma de quartz gluon un
état de la matière ne pouvant être
atteint quatre températures
incroyablement élevé et en sans doute
existé dans les de la création de
l'univers impressionnant mais en dessous
des quads des types de trous noirs
extrêmement massifs au centre des
galaxies paradoxalement ils sont très
lumineux vu qu'autour 2 gravitent des
millions d'étoiles entraînés dans une
danse frénétique jusqu'à 28 millions de
km/h le plus gigantesque de tous c'est
Tom 618 aussi lumineux que 140000
milliards de soleil éclipsant tout ce
qu'il y a autour s'il était à seulement
187 années-lumière de nous il nous
apparaîtrait comme un deuxième soleil en
comparaison je vous rappelle que Alpha
sentori l'étoile la plus proche est
seulement à 4,37 années-lumière de nu
mais ça ne serait pas génial parce que
les quasars sont meurtriers énormément
de gaz brûlants s'accumulent au pôle
projeté dans un rayon de plasma ultra
concentré jusqu'à 99% de la Vitesse
Lumière encore un record et attention ça
chauffe le quasar le plus proche de nous
trois c273 tirent des rayons de 10000
milliards de degrés voyages en plus loin
qu'aucune autre source lumineuse
théoriquement il n'y a pas de limite à
la chaleur mais dans les faits il y a
une élite qui ne sera jamais égalé c'est
la température supposée du Big Bang la
température de Planck 142 milliards de
milliards de milliards 2 milliards de
Kelvin figurez-vous qu'il reste des
records à égaler votre Soleil est une
petite étoile avant de mourir il va
gonfler puis s'effondrer sur lui-même
pour former une aide blanche un cadavre
inoffensif et peut brillant si le destin
de toutes les étoiles dont la masse est
inférieure à 10 fois celle du soleil
au-dessus de 30 masses solaires c'est
beaucoup plus violent une implosion en
Super Nova qui laissera en son cœur un
trou noir stelaire pour les étoiles ni
trop petite ni trop grosses leur destin
est de devenir une étoile à neutrons
après l'explosion la masse qui s'effond
n'est pas suffisante pour former un trou
noir alors les particules se contractent
et forment des neutrons jusqu'à
atteindre un nouvel équilibre il reste
un astre minuscule incroyablement dense
une cuillère à café pèserait un milliard
de tonnes encore merci à cybergots VPN
d'avoir sponsorisé cette vidéo n'oubliez
pas de profiter des 83% de réduction et
4 mois gratuits satisfait ou remboursé
sous 45 jours avec le lien en
description tous les records dont on a
parlé aujourd'hui
seront peut-être obsolètes dans quelques
années c'est ça qui est frustrant avec
l'astrophysique par exemple qu'est-ce
qu'il y a derrière notre Soleil en
orbite avec nous ou derrière l'immense
au hasard de notre galaxie faute de
pouvoir voir à travers on ne peut que le
déduire avec des calculs encore faut-il
qu'il soit bon matière noire énergie
noire courant noire autant d'énigmes qui
viennent changer notre façon de
modéliser le monde et les Femen qui en
résultent le ciel décidément ne cessera
jamais de nous faire rêver
[Musique]